se acerca de dos meses Finalizó el
polémico título 42 y desde entonces se
tenía una afluencia masiva de migrantes
intentando cruzar la frontera entre
Estados Unidos y México Pero ha ocurrido
todo lo contrario
Así que lo que hemos visto desde el
final del título 42 es una disminución
en nuestras aprensiones para el mes de
junio en este momento estamos
promediando más de 430 presiones por día
eso es en el sector de El Paso
comparándolo con el más alto que hemos
visto este año fiscal que fue el año
pasado de 2700 por día
al título 42 siguieron nuevas normas
implementadas por el presidente Joe
biden para reprimir los cruces
irregulares los migrantes deben ahora
pedir asilo desde otro país ya una
aplicación móvil o haber visto su
demanda de asilo rechazada en un país
por el que hayan transitado y a los que
se sorprenda cruzando de forma irregular
se le impondrá un ve para entrar al país
por al menos cinco años es por eso que
si antes muchos intentaban pasar la
frontera en más de una oportunidad las
más recientes políticas migratorias los
obligan ahora a esperar en México por un
proceso que puede tomar meses o años
bueno todos los días igual porque uno se
va al parque allá vende porque sale a
Pedida y BS y veces no pide y así A
veces como un mar además para muchos el
uso de la aplicación es difícil no
tienen teléfonos adecuados o un buen
acceso a internet
empujar a los migrantes de tenerlos
abandonarlos o hacer deliberadamente el
proceso tan difícil que abandonen su
búsqueda para llegar a Estados Unidos es
una política cruel que solo pone en
riesgo a las personas Aunque yo Byron
había prometido un sistema migratorio
más humano que el de su predecesor a día
de hoy no lo ha logrado